welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Whitney van laningham and even though
we're already two movies deep into phase
five of the MCU I still have so many
leftover questions from phase four that
I need answers to before I can truly
move on and listen I get it miss me and
Marvel have spoiled us all with an
abundance of answers at a relatively
quick Pace if Disney hadn't taken over
Star Wars fans would have had to wait a
lot longer than 38 years to find out if
Boba Fett survived that sarlacc pit but
there's a few things from this last
phase that I just can't stop thinking
about so today I'm going over all of the
biggest unanswered questions in Unsolved
Mysteries from recent MCU shows and
movies as the late Robert Stack once
said for every mystery there is someone
somewhere who knows the truth perhaps
that someone is watching perhaps it's
you first we obviously have to hit the
number one question on every MCU Fan's
mind what is going on with tiamat's
corpse there have literally been six
movies four TV shows a horror special
and a holiday special since the eternals
why when we gotten a single solid update
we've seen exactly two small references
to Tiamat in the aftermath of the
emergence at the ending of the eternals
Kota News in South Dakota broadcast a
segment about the unidentified
marbleized rock formation including a
Chiron that says scientists suggest
appearance of object could be associated
with the Blitz the newscaster confirms
the U.S and Australian naval ships are
in defense positions in the Indian Ocean
defensive positions you guys did that
well authorities Scramble for answers
but at this point if their best theory
is that this is just a blip side effect
they're pretty far behind on the latest
interdimensional and Intergalactic
threats in episode 2 of She-Hulk when
Jen is looking for jobs you can see a
tiny side article titled why is there a
giant man sticking out of the ocean but
that's the last time we heard of that
big bald baby this is really surprising
because the MCU has previously been so
great at exploring the aftermath and
repercussions of major superhero related
events they've really nailed the
depictions of regular and super-powered
people alike coping with a sudden loss
of half of all life in the galaxy and
this wasn't the first instance from
detailing the emotions and realities of
the aftermath of sokovia's Destruction
to the payoff of Captain America lifting
Thor's hammer Marvel has rewarded us
with answers to our most burning
questions time and again so why haven't
they updated us on the aftermath of TMX
half-assed birth the real answer is
probably pretty simple it just hasn't
come up in a way that would be
meaningful to the current storyline
they're trying to unfold Our Heroes have
been busy with other stuff my favorite
theory about why tmed isn't front and
center and the News cycle came from my
buddy Mt he has the best series of all
time so go check out his Twitter if you
haven't already Mt thinks that sword or
the dodc have staged a massive cover-up
of tiamat's corpse similar to the way
that Shield covered up extraterrestrial
Encounters in the past and with
Scientists blaming the blip authorities
might have encouraged the rumor that
Thanos was at fault for the emergence if
Val and the dodc turn out to be the
masterminds behind gaslighting the
public into believing that a big old
dead guy in the ocean isn't an
Intergalactic problem how hopefully
we'll see their Sinister manipulation
plot played out in the future I have a
second question from the eternals what's
up with Pip arrows and the other
eternals the last time we saw Cersei she
fastos and Kingo were yanked out of the
sky by erisham another planet-sized dude
who no one seems to be talking about and
the remaining crew was on their way to
rescue them pip and Star Fox pop aboard
their spaceship offering to help Cena
Makari Andrew rescue their friends again
that's the last we heard from them Bane
Whitman seems to be the only person
losing a over Cersei getting
plucked like a daisy by a gigantic alien
robot and zero references to erisham's
appearance over England have been made
mg's Theory definitely fits this
situation as well and lack of public
knowledge about the eternals their
Origins and their sacrifice certainly
helped slow the theory now the people of
616 can't be afraid of what they don't
know if absolutely no one has offered a
real explanation to worldwide Outlets
the general population probably isn't
having an existential crisis even though
the plot of this movie basically
confirms that there is no God if Earth
does find out about the celestials we
probably won't hear about it until
eternals too which so far isn't slated
for phases 5 or 6. Kevin feige did
confirm in an interview with MTV News at
San Diego Comic-Con in 2022 that Harry
Styles will return to the MCU but where
in the comics arrows does interact with
Marvel and Monica Rambo but I can't see
the Eternal showing up in the Marvels on
their way to save their homies we might
just have to wait until eternals 2 is
announced in late phase 6-7 or beyond my
third question is where did Clea take
doctor strange and his freaky forehead
at the end of Multiverse of Madness
obviously we very clearly saw her slice
open a portal to the dark dimension but
I'm gonna need some more details your
mama was still alive and well despite
his banishment isn't he gonna be pissed
when his least favorite guy to bargain
with comes through
[Music]
I've come to bargain even if Daddy
dormammu doesn't get mad at his daughter
for bringing a three-eyed sorcerer into
their Dimension strange is gonna have
other problems like for example where
CLIA might be taking him depending on
her solution for stopping incursions the
two of them could be anywhere in the
Multiverse in the comics however we
learned that the easiest way to stop an
incursion is to Simply destroy one of
the worlds before they Collide the Black
Swan AKA Our Lady of the Apocalypse
tells Reed Richards doctor strange and
other Heroes that she knows eight
different ways to stop an incursion but
wiping one of the Earth's involved out
of existence is the simplest most
Surefire way to do it my hope is that
we'll see CLIA and Doctor Strange try
out several different ways to stop the
incursions before resorting to the death
of an entire planet although the comics
didn't specify the details of the seven
other ways to thwart an incursion it
would be really exciting to see them
test out these other methods I also
wonder if the next Doctor Strange will
address the consequences of Venom
leaving a piece of itself behind in the
MCU in the aftermath of no way home this
not only means that we'll likely see
Venom infect a new host in 616. it also
means that Dr Strange and Clea might
need to deal with this multiversal
trespasser on their quest to stop the
incursion if the only way to stop an
incursion is to destroy the world
colliding with 616. I have a theory that
we could see them Evacuate the other
reality possibly bringing Eddie Brock
and Venom back to 616 to reunite with
their lost goo but there may be a snag
in my theory according to Charlize
Theron who plays Clea in the MCU she
hasn't heard anything about her
character's return in an interview with
MTV Theron claimed that she still hasn't
gotten a call from Marvel with an update
on her role for the next phase and a
half already slated I'm not sure we'll
see these two together for a while we
made this video with the help of geology
and with their help you can make your
skin healthier than ever geology is a
22-time award-winning skin hair and body
care company recognized in men's health
Oprah daily hypebeast birdie Esquire and
GQ their products are built around just
a handful of powerful proven ingredients
that have been trusted by dermatologists
for decades just take a quick 30 second
diagnostic quiz and geology will create
a simple and effective skin care or hair
care routine customized just for you
geology's co-wash and deodorant are
great and I use them all the time but
right now they're running a special
offer for a skincare sampler Pat and
geology skincare stuff is in a league of
its own geology's line of skin care
products can help you fight acne reduce
oiliness prevent wrinkles combat dark or
puffy under eyes have smoother hydrated
skin and Target signs of aging there's
never been a better time to try geology
than right now for a very limited time
use code rockstars 100 to get 100 off of
your personalized 30-day skincare sample
set all you have to do is cover the 495
for shipping on top of that new
rockstars fans get an exclusive bonus
offer of up to 50 off on an additional
skin hair and body product of your
choice when you add it to your trial
click the link in the description or go
to
geolog.i.e rockstars100 to get started
fourth question what's going on with
shangshi's sister xylang and the new 10
Rings although Shane cheese confirmed
for a sequel we haven't heard any
updates on when it might join one of the
mcu's future phases it makes sense even
though it feels like that movie came out
a billion years ago it's only two years
old for those of us living in pandemic
time that roughly equates to about 10
years but in the MCU that's like 10
minutes ago we're definitely gonna find
out that xylang has been spending her
time between movies further training the
former staff of the golden daggers Club
to become the next generation of 10
Rings Warriors my fifth question is who
the hell bought Avengers Towers in
Hawkeye Clint told Kate that Tony sold
it a few years ago and in Spider-Man far
from home we see Peter swing past the
building's New Garden Lounge in the
center of the building but we still
don't know who owns the tower in 616.
well actually I do know who bought
Avengers Tower and there are a lot of
theories have the Fantastic Four taken
over Avengers Tower to transform it into
their headquarters aka the Baxter
building some fans think that the sign
in the background reading we can't wait
to show you what comes next with the
numbers one two three and a question
mark is a hint that the Fantastic Four
might be the new tenants others others a
yet unseen Norman Osborne variant could
be the buyer although the MCU doesn't
currently have its own version of
Osborne I've seen some speculation that
we might get our own 616 version in the
future anything is possible but this is
one of the less likely theories in my
opinion Willem Dafoe is too classic to
replace so soon after no way home so if
they do cast an alternate reality
version I don't think it'll be for a few
more phases up six is Hercules on his
way to try to kill thoria obviously Thor
4 was a pretty recent addition and it
makes sense that we don't have an answer
to this yet but I'm still Mega curious
Thor just became a stepdad and now the
son of Zeus is tasked with murdering him
what's Hercules gonna do track him down
it loves Chuck E cheese birthday party
and stab him with a lightning bolt my
seventh question technically isn't from
phase four but it came to mind with
Multiverse Madness so it still counts
where the hell is Baron mordo the
original one not the very we haven't
seen him since the post-credits scene of
Doctor Strange all the way back in Phase
3 where he removed Jonathan pangborn's
Powers re-paralyzing him and Kicking off
his quest to read the world of sorcerers
in an interview with total film back in
2022 after Joetta 4 confirmed that his
character wasn't part of the snaps away
group and that he was definitely engaged
at the time so this dude witnessed half
of all life in the universe disappear
and still thought magicians were the
problem that's some serious dedication
to hating sorcery half of all the
sorcerers in the entire galaxy were
wiped off the list mordo was like I'm
just getting started baby interestingly
we did learn in the Disney plus
documentary assembled the making of
Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of
Madness that is seen where Wanda forces
mordo to decapitate himself with a sword
was cut from the final version of the
film without that ending for the
character however we're left wondering
where that guy is wandering my guess is
that his beef with lizards will
eventually lead him back to Wong and
kamritage which leads me to my final
question is Madison still hanging out
with Wong did he take her back for
commodage with him to help him set up a
variety of streaming services with their
impeccable Wi-Fi I think answer is yes
for starters convertage collects cool
people like Pokemon cards they lured in
Doctor Strange American Chavez and
Abomination their track record of
convincing people to come hang out at
their cool magic dwelling is solid
secondly at the end of She-Hulk Waters
confesses that he was late to bust Emile
Blonsky out of jail again because he got
caught up watching a TV show again Emil
my apologies for the delay endless Some
people prefer to binge watch TV alone
and I respect that but personally my
favorite thing to do is invite my best
friend Lisa over to eat snacks with me
while we catch up on Shark Tank and
ghosts I think Wong totally invited her
back to comritage so that they could
re-watch Buffy the Vampire Slayer from
start to finish Plus Madison loves
partying in weird new places she's not
gonna say no to a free vacay with magic
tricks and I'm not the only one who
thinks that they deserve a Hobson shot
spin-off treatment she helps director
cat coiro told Mashable in an interview
that she thinks that Madison and Wong
should have their own movie I 100 agree
and if you don't want to see Wong's
world you can get out right now I'll
admit that none of the theoretical
answers I've presented to these
questions are 100 solid and we won't
uncover the truth behind these Mysteries
until further down the line but it's fun
to speculate the first two is fun then
scary then fun again Eric has you
covered on the scroll search mystery and
talking about Val's vibranium deserves
its own video so I want to hear all of
your theories about these Topics in the
comments why isn't anyone talking about
Tiamat what other sorcerers has mordo
killed are Madison and Wong caught up on
Yellow Jackets yet follow me on
Instagram and Twitter whitneypuppy
Fallen rockstars subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love and thanks for
watching bye
[Music]